Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue over metal.
This episode is brought to you by [inaudible] dot com the world's largest on
demand massage service.
What?
And let me tell you,
I have a high bar for this stuff.
I have body work done at least once a week because I broke my body.
I have 30 plus fractures and hundred plus Mris.
I need bodywork,
so I have a very,
very,
very high bar for that sooth which I've tested.
I tested my assistance,
tested my employees tested,
delivers a hint,
selected,
licensed and experienced massage therapist to you in the comfort of your own
home,
hotel or office in as little as an hour.
I've tested them in San Francisco,
I've tested them at Austin,
have tested them all over the place and I have to say I was really,
really amazed at the quality of therapist and I do not accept mediocrity at all
in this area.
The process is super simple.
Think of it as Uber for massages,
right?
You choose the kind of massage you want,
say Swedish or sports massage,
deep tissue,
whatever.
Then a,
if you want,
you can opt for a couple's massage.
I imagine that's an edge case as the tech people say,
but whatever you sit,
the lengthier massage,
so let's say you want 60 minutes,
90 minutes,
two hours,
and let's be real.
If you want a proper massage,
go for 90 or 120 minutes for God's sake and you select the gender of your
therapist and then click you're off to the races and they bring the massage
table sheets,
oil music,
so you can unwind no matter where you are.
And I've used this at Airbnbs,
hotels,
et Cetera,
as in 50 cities,
including most major US cities as well as a London,
Sydney,
Melbourne,
Toronto,
and Vancouver.
So number one,
download the APP,
sooth,
s,
O,
t,
h,
e in the ios app store,
Google play store,
and then use the t the code.
Let me try that again and use the Code Titan 20 t I t a n two zero titan 20 all
caps to get $20 off of your first massage.
That's a lot.
That's a very good discount.
So you should use it.
So again,
download the APP,
sooth s,
O,
t,
h e and try out the code tight in 20 all caps for $20 not percent $20 off your
first massage.
And if you're anything like me,
I have been paying and I've been enjoying.
So give it a shot.
Try out sooth and your muscles.
Nervous system and sleep well.
Thank you for it.
What the fuck gotta read was that it was pretty good.
That's what I think.
Okay,
enjoy.
Bye.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
I have used legal zoom myself for many of my businesses and many of the icons on
this podcast have actually used legal zoom.
For instance,
Matt Mullenweg of wordpress fame see of automatic,
which is now worth more than a billion dollars first incorporated his company on
legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses.
Whether that's setting up a will,
doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit or finding simple cease and desist letter templates.
Man,
do I use a lot of those?
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they do have a network of independent attorneys available in most states.
They can give you advice on the best way to get started,
provide contract reviews and otherwise help you run your business and important,
there are no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency.
That means upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout Legal zoom.com today to see how they can make life better and easier
for you and your business.
If you're pretending to be a lawyer on the Internet,
then you are asking for trouble.
Put together the safety nets.
Get your t's crossed and your I's dotted.
Enter Promo Code Tim tim@legalzoom.com to save 15% that's t I m for 15% off.
Check it out.
Legal zoom.com
hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job.
To deconstruct world class performers to figure out how they do what they do and
to dig into the details that you can apply to your own life.
And this episode,
we have a treat.
We do not have an entertainer.
We do not have an actor.
We do not have a military strategist.
We have a performance specialist,
specifically athletic performance,
and Ryan flirty on Instagram at Ryan flirty one the number one was introduced to
me by Dr Peter a Tia.
And those of you who have heard my episodes with Peter [inaudible] know that
many good things come from Peter.
This is no different.
Uh,
Ryan flarity is the senior director of performance at Nike.
Prior to holding that position,
Ryan was the founder and president of prolific athletes,
LLC,
a sports performance facility in San Diego,
California,
where he trained some of the world's best athletes.
His clients include,
you may have recognized or heard of these names,
Serena Williams,
Russell Wilson,
the Arizona cardinals,
Marcus Mariota,
Jamis,
Winston,
and hundreds of other professional athletes.
And while he's perhaps best known for dramatically improving his athletes,
athletes,
that's the right word.
Speed.
More and more athletes and coaches see crying out for his training and guidance
on injury prevention and we dig really deeply into that.
In this episode.
Many of his clients have made remarkable recoveries from injuries and several
NFL teams and European soccer clubs have sought out his methodology to implement
into their own training programming.
Ryan developed an algorithm called a forced number that is based on the trap bar
dead lift,
also called the hex bar dead lift and body weight to predict speed such as the
40 yard dash.
This was a really fun interview.
We got into the weeds.
We got very,
very nerdy.
If you enjoy it.
For instance,
the Pavel Tsatsouline episodes,
the Charles Pollock went episodes,
Dominic D'Agostino or Peter Tia,
then you're going to love this one.
It takes us a few minutes as it almost always does to warm up.
That's a limbering up round.
And then we get into all sorts of stuff.
We talk about exercises for reducing injury potential.
We talk about the uh,
forced number and exactly how he uses the trap bar deadlift.
What do exact workouts look like?
Sets and reps rest intervals,
lay it out,
start to finish from warmup.
What does one of these workouts look like?
We talked about glutamine exercises.
Perhaps you saw some in tools of titans in Peter t as profile.
That was a directly from Ryan and variations.
We get into all sorts of nitty gritty details.
Uh,
how he helped Meb Keflezighi.
I think it is trained for his stunning Boston marathon victory.
How does he go from sprinting to long distance running?
How does he predict which athletes are going to get injured?
Uh,
so whether you are trying to become a better athlete,
you are trying to become less injured,
are more resilient in any type of training,
uh,
or maybe if you're a bookie looking to bet on different teams and athletes or
bet short certain teams that are going to get injured.
There is something for everyone.
So please enjoy my conversation with Ryan Flaherty,
the savant of speed.
Ryan,
welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me.
Appreciate it.
I have been hoping to connect for quite a few months now and we've had a few
actors behind the scene trying to connect us.
I know for a few months and here we are.
So I'm super stoked to dig in and I thought we could just start with some
basics.
So you are very well known for saying that speed is teachable,
coachable,
but almost everyone out there says it is not,
it is a Nate.
So how did you come to that conclusion?
Sure.
I mean,
you know,
first and foremost,
I think when I was at,
when I was a young kid,
kind of a funny story,
but when I was young I was a playing baseball and um,
both my parents were athletic and,
and um,
you know,
so they kind of knew some things about sports and I was the,
hit it.
I was at bat,
I hit a line drive to center field and I got thrown out at first base and,
uh,
I can remember my dad yelling unhitch the trailer as I was running,
I was running so slow basically,
which is not a good thing for a young kid to hear from his dad,
um,
uh,
in third grade.
But I was,
I was a US really slow kid when I was young.
I grew fast and,
and just couldn't develop speed.
Uh,
all the kids were faster than me and my class and my teams.
And so my mom actually put me into track and field when I was young and,
uh,
about fourth grade.
And by the time I was in fifth,
sixth grade,
I was the fastest kid in my school.
Um,
and,
and what a lot of that was from was just me understanding and learning how to
run properly.
And so once I did that kind of opened my eyes to the idea that,
you know,
obviously it was not something I was born with in any way,
but it's something that was learned and it was a skill that I really put a lot
of time into understanding and learning.
And,
you know,
as I've gotten older and I've,
I've,
I've been in the sports performance training field for a long time.
Um,
one of the things that,
um,
I think is,
you know,
kind of funny to me as I point out to a lot of people and parents is that,
if you can imagine if every sport played was in the,
in the swimming pool,
one of the first things most kids would do and would be learn how to swim.
And yet every single sport right on ground is,
requires running.
And yet we don't teach kids how to run.
It's just kind of like throw them into the sport and they'll figure it out.
But,
um,
that's one of the big things I think I've been trying to help educate people on
is that the one most important thing you can do for your child is just teach
them how to run properly.
And then every other sport we'll kind of come easily to them.
And I think,
um,
you know,
over the years,
more and more research putting into this,
I've,
I've come to realize quickly through,
you know,
just the research is that a speed is actually a skill you can learn it and some
that you can train also.
And it,
I mean it seems to me like you have,
just as you said,
I didn't learn to swim.
Speaking as someone who's extremely terrified of swimming and for a host of
reasons,
didn't learn to swim properly until early thirties.
Yes,
it is.
It is incredible that anything on land that is dependent in part,
whether it's NFL combine and you're doing something like a shuttle run,
I mean the difference between first place and say third,
fourth or also ran is highly dependent on,
on the technique number one,
but also certain attributes that you can develop.
And I'd look for you to share with us perhaps some of the experiments that,
uh,
you did at USA track to figure out how to better coach speed.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So what I ended up taking,
I needed a sample size that are all like some skill level and talent level.
And so,
um,
I took 30 Olympic a standards,
sprinters and random on force plate treadmills.
And so the Olympic Games,
there's spinners,
spinners that have hit the required marks to,
to qualify for the Olympics.
Now in the United States is different.
Just because we're,
we're,
we're such a high level that you have to be much better than,
than just the standard,
but in other countries and a lot of other countries,
you'd be hit the standard you're in.
Um,
and so I took,
I took Olympic ice standard sprinters and I test them on a force plate
treadmill.
And,
and what I quickly realized was it wasn't about how much force they were created
or how great their technique was.
Um,
it wasn't really until I realized that,
I think,
I know you're familiar with the study that was done by doctor Peter Way and,
um,
which is mass specific force is,
is kind of king.
It's,
it's,
it's more than anything.
It's how much force you can create or what's your body mass is.
So,
uh,
to use an as example,
it'd be like if I told you,
go run a hundred meter dash as fast,
you could with a 50 pound weight vest on and I,
you know,
and recording your time and then we took it off and then we recorded your time.
You'd be much faster without the 50 pound weight vest on.
Well and firstly,
if you were just an increased somebody lower body strength by 50 pounds,
without adding a single pound of lean muscle mass,
you'd also have the same results,
um,
with improving their times based on them improving the lower body strength and
to mass ratio.
And so quickly,
I,
you know,
through the study of all the athletes,
I realized,
okay,
so,
so majority,
majority of what it comes down to for sprinters are for people to be fast as
they have an insane amount of strength over what their body mass is.
So an incredible ratio between that strength to weight ratio.
Um,
and so with every FDA train now,
whether it's Serena Williams on the tennis court or,
or you know,
a football player that's going into the NFL combine,
um,
it's a,
it's about teaching them how to improve that strength,
strength to weight ratio without increasing any lean muscle mass.
So,
um,
I think that's,
that's the key.
And then,
and then secondarily to that,
you know,
mechanics play a part and um,
part of those mechanics,
if you imagine a,
when you run,
when you watch an athlete run from the side of their foot in their swing phase,
when they're running,
looks like it makes,
it's making a circle.
Well,
if,
if you have a big circle,
a big wheel that would cover a larger distance than a smaller wheel will.
And so what I try to do is help them understand how to make larger wheels with
their feet in order for them to cover more ground,
which increases their stride length,
which in turn helps them run faster.
Times.
Like to give you an example of Usain bolt takes four to two steps around our,
your dash next best guy in the world takes 44.
And so ultimately what you're trying to do in improving somebody's speed is
helping them limit the amount of steps they take to run whatever particular
distance they're going,
whether it's a marathon or it's a hundred meter dash,
which is also a,
in some respects,
very comparable to Olympic swimming.
Right?
I mean you look at the stride length and efficiency of top swimmers and there's,
there's a direct parallel,
just to just a side note,
I guess,
which I've always wondered,
you hear a lot say in certain running communities,
uh,
about striking with the mid foot and so on.
Uh,
how much attention do you pay to the,
uh,
the,
the impact point on the foot when you're trying to say increase the size of that
wheel,
does that naturally lead to more,
uh,
impact closer to the heel or is that,
is that something that has been over emphasized?
I don't think it's been over emphasized as much as it as it is,
the placement underneath the pelvis.
So I think more than anything,
it's kind of like where the foot striking him in relation to the center of mass
is most important.
So when you're looking at somebody who's with a mid foot strikes,
so I do focus on mid foot strike,
but more than anything I focused on where that midfoot striker is occurring,
whether it's occurring,
you know,
out middle meters in front of the pelvis of directly under the pelvis or behind,
uh,
the goal is to get it as underneath the pelvis as possible.
So you want the mid foot strike to happen under the pelvis,
which is more of what I focus on,
um,
in that big circle and the mechanic and the teaching of the mechanics with
making that he'll,
you know,
if you can imagine the heels stepping over your opposite knee when you sprint is
the goal.
And so,
and then upon ground contact and the landing phase,
you want the foot to be as directly under the pelvis as possible.
And for sprinters,
do you,
how much do you think about stride rate people have read born to run?
There are many books and they talking about,
well you should go from say 90 and aim for 180 and you should use some type of
metronome or,
or auditory feedback so that you're increasing your,
um,
your steps,
foot falls per minute effectively.
How do you think about that in the context of what you do if,
if you do it all?
Yeah,
totally.
No,
I absolutely do.
And I think,
I think the biggest thing is,
it's again,
everything I'm going to talk about today,
it's all about specificity.
As you know,
like once if you're training for performance and for particular sport
performance,
then you're going to train a very particular way that we're focused on,
on,
you know,
the minutia of,
of those things that that will best help that person perform better.
However,
when you're,
when you're transitioning into more of like a,
you know,
a static runner or just in terms of training for health,
a lot of what I'm going to say may not always apply it,
but it could,
can't apply it in certain ways.
And so I think,
uh,
with that being said,
I think,
you know,
the way I look at his stride length and stride frequency for the majority of the
time,
our products of how much force you create with the ground of what your body
weight is.
So your mass specific force,
your stride rate,
stride rate and,
and length is actually a product of that.
So more than anything,
instead of focusing on that,
I'm focusing on,
on,
on on one hand the mechanics of sprinting.
But I'm also focused on if I know if I can improve strength to weight ratio in
the weight room,
which I think we can get into a little bit more depth later is I know for a fact
that stride length and stride frequency we'll also improved.
Those are byproducts.
Exactly.
And so instead of focusing on one or the other,
I just focused on the one that affects the other.
I'm sorry,
I'm so excited to jump into,
I'll get a little overzealous.
Go ahead.
No,
no,
no worries.
And I think that's the biggest thing of all my,
all the research I've done,
even in the weight room is I'm looking at the exercises that can have the
greatest effect and in a multitude of ways,
not just in one specific area.
So I think because athletes just like human beings have,
have a limited amount of time they have in a day,
they don't want it,
they can't.
And,
and trainers can't spend that amount of time in the weight room that,
that most people think they can because they have all these other things going
on,
you know?
And so it's what can I get the most bang for my buck to improve the most amount
of things in the shortest period of time is what I do with elite level athletes,
just like I would with CEOs or recommended for,
you know,
other people in terms of that don't have the time to spend two hours in a gym.
Um,
you want to get the most bang for your buck.
And so I've really focused on researching exercises that give you that in order
for them to get the greatest improvement.
Could you,
and this might be a good place you tell me to segue or it's not really a segue
cause it's all very related,
uh,
force number.
Can you about what that is?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And so,
so when I was studying feed and sprinters with USA Track and field,
what I,
what I found quickly was that once the,
once the sprinters hit a certain,
um,
distance,
right around 30 to 40 meters,
they actually maintained and held the exact same split for the rest of the race.
Uh,
it was actually the athletes who ran the fast times like Usain bolts of the
world.
We're actually the ones who we're slowing down the lease.
But really when you looked at their 10 meters splits,
it was almost identical all the way through to the finish.
Um,
and so what I,
what I,
um,
when it came to realized quickly was that there was a correlation there between
who could hold a top end speed the longest and who was winning the race.
And so,
um,
when I was looking at that and then then inversely was looking at the athletes
and measuring their mass specific force.
And the force plate treadmill.
What I realized quickly was,
okay,
there's relation to the athletes who have a high strength to weight ratio or the
or the force to mass specific force,
uh,
forced to mass ratio and the treadmill that also are covering the same,
you know,
lowest splits and their 10 meters,
the 10,
they're flying tens in the hundred meter dash that all of the athletes came to
me after that and were like,
this is awesome.
This is great,
you know,
but like,
hey,
how do we have,
how do we improve this?
And it was,
it was kind of a light bulb that went on for me really quickly was that I think
what most researchers scientists spend time looking into is diagnostics and
assessments.
But what most people really need is,
is ways to improve it.
So unless you come with a diagnostic that you can actually show them improvement
and show them how to improve it,
they're almost meaningless.
Um,
and so I,
I,
what I,
what I spent the next five years doing was spending time in the weight room and,
and,
and correlating the data between every exercise.
I,
so I tested the same athletes in the weight room on with squat power,
clean hang in front squats,
leg press,
leg extension,
um,
Rdo,
everything you can think of under the sun and the,
and measured there one rep Max and those exercises and their body and their body
mass and compared that to the force plate treadmill study.
And it didn't correlate until actually got to the hex bar dead lift,
which is also called the trap bar dead lift for so yup.
Exactly
their bar that you stepped into with the handles on the side of the body instead
of the bar being in front.
Right.
And then when I,
when I started testing the same athletes with the hex bar dead lift for the trap
bar,
dead lift Max in their body weight,
it actually directly correlated to the force plate treadmill study,
um,
at their max velocity and top speed.
And so I realized quickly,
okay,
if this is the order in which they ran the hundred meter dash time in by their
hex bar,
dead lift Max and body weight and I improve their hex bar dead lift Max without
increasing bodyweight,
what I see the same improvement their speed.
And over the past seven years of testing that I have,
if you have a
not totally sit entry but former competitive athlete who would like to use a
protocol to improve this relative strength that we've been talking about,
sort of pound per pound strength output using the trap bar deadlift or hex bar w
w what might the protocol look like?
You know,
for most people I would,
I would generally start them with somewhat of a hypertrophy or strength phase
for a while just to get them used to the lift and you to get,
you know,
get their lower back strong enough to be able to get to the power phases.
What would that first hypertrophy fees look like?
Yeah.
So I would go,
I mean I would do probably three to four sets of eight of your 65% of your Max
for um,
one to two weeks.
And then I would,
I would,
I would shift up 5%,
uh,
every week leading up to about 85,
90%,
where I would go for reps of five or three.
So based on the percentage of your that you're lifting,
um,
so let's say it's 65%,
you're going to be between six to eight range there.
When you start to get 75,
80%,
you want to be in the five to eight rep range.
And then when you get above 85% to 95%,
you want to be between two reps in five reps.
So more than anything.
And what you're trying to do ultimately is with the amount of cross sectional
muscle fiber that your body currently has,
you're trying to stress your nervous system,
recruit the largest motor units possible.
Um,
and to do that you have to lift heavy.
You have to lift heavy weights in order to recruit the larger motor units.
Because ultimately what most people do when they exercise and they lift weights
is that they're,
they're,
they're stressing their body,
essentially.
ISOMETRIC concentrically and they're adding lean muscle mass.
They're also recruiting motor units,
but they're also,
but they're also adding the muscle mass at the same rate.
What we're trying to do,
and the cool part about the hex bar,
dead lift is at the very top.
When you,
when you push away from the ground and you're in a standing position away from
the ground,
I actually am going to coach you guys to let go of the bar to drop it.
So there's no east centric movement in the,
in the,
and the exercise.
So that way you don't tear sarcoma and lean muscle mass.
Um,
and,
and that,
so your stress,
the nervous system to get stronger,
recruit large motor units,
but you're not actually tearing muscle fiber down and adding more muscle mass.
Um,
and so I would go every two weeks.
I would just adjust 5% um,
and,
and go up 5% and for about four to eight reps for 65% I would say four to six
reps for like 70 75% four to five reps for 85% and then two to three reps for a
95 to 90% and just progressed that way.
And everyone,
it's all relative.
So it doesn't mean everyone's going to live to 500 pounds,
but,
but ultimately what you're trying to get to is an elite level football player,
like a four or five 40 yard dash four four 40 yard dash would be a 3.2 times
their body weight in their export dead lift to run that time.
3.2 times body weight.
Yeah.
And,
and what I find is in,
in,
in most like,
you know,
a healthy adults,
they can,
they can generally pull about anywhere from 2.2 to 2.6 times their body weight
in,
in the annex bar dead lift Max.
And what,
what would be a,
a good objective if perhaps 3.2,
uh,
w what would you,
from the outset,
if you said in a,
in a year's time,
I would like to get you to x times body weight.
And does it differ for men or women or is it the same?
No,
actually you don't,
it's kind of funny if it's the same.
I,
the funny part is is when I have like,
so right now I'm training a lot of the top NFL draft hopefuls guys that just
finished their college career.
Um,
and then they come in the weight room,
they'll see,
you know,
some of the female Olympic that I have
training and the females are who are 135 pounds or dead lifting 440 pounds,
and they'll walk in the first day and they'll hit three 85 and it immediately
humbles them to realize what have I been doing for the past four years of my
life.
Uh,
because those women over there are dead lifting 100 pounds more than I am.
Um,
but it's pretty funny.
But when they weigh 80 pounds less.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So no,
no,
I think,
um,
you know,
I mean I think reasonably over the course of two years a question like what
could people get to over the course of a year
goal for someone who's reasonably fit,
but by no means a NCAA or Olympic sprinter
over two is a,
is a great goal for somebody like that.
Got It.
And that is for one rep maximum or four four given wreck
rep range.
Yeah.
So I think,
oh over two times their body weight for a one rep maximum.
So,
so to give you an example,
let's say you're a hundred pounds,
your goal's 200 pounds.
Um,
you know,
for sets of five,
you going to want to do,
um,
170 pounds for five.
That would be,
you know,
to get you up to 200 as your Max got would be 85% of your Max.
Got It.
So 85% times five,
five reps.
Got it.
And,
uh,
when,
when someone goes through the,
the muscle building general sort of hypertrophy,
a base building,
once they've done that in,
they're working on the relative strength and the neural drive and the recruiting
of these motor units,
uh,
and focusing on that,
how many times a week are they doing a trap bar,
dead lift workout and what would such a workout look like?
Sure.
Yeah.
So I mean for the elite level athletes,
generally I'll have them do it anywhere between one to two times a week.
Uh,
just depends on the amount of time I have with them.
for certain athletes like Serena Williams and I work with her in the off season,
I would generally have,
or like in November or December.
So I only have two months with her.
So it's all kind of east or into it and build up to two times a week towards the
end.
But if you have a long period of time,
I would go one day a week and then alternate with another complex exercise.
The second lower body day you do that week.
Um,
but I think two times a week.
And you know,
if it starting a hypertrophy phase,
I would say four times at eight,
at 65%.
Um,
I like to pair it,
you know,
uh,
with,
with some sort of plyometric to continue to recruit those fast twitch,
those larger motor units.
Um,
and then,
and then from there I go into all like auxiliary single leg unilateral exercises
to you fix imbalances are trained the the body in a way that,
um,
we're,
we're not working bilaterally besides that one x bar dead lift.
So I would do an export data for the Plyo and then some,
a couple of single leg exercises.
I love to dig into some details.
So let's just say,
let's pretend since I need the,
the pat on the head,
let's pretend like I'm an elite athlete,
which I'm not,
but let's just say I'm ready.
Sure.
I'm coming in to do this workout and my body's prepped for it.
So I walk in,
what does the warmup look like?
And then when you get into the dead lifts,
what are the sets and reps and rest intervals like Wah.
Walk me through the details of what that end of course,
it's highly individualized.
You can just make up some,
uh,
we don't even need to get into the numbers.
You could use percentages,
but,
um,
what would the warmup and the whole thing look like?
Yeah,
so generally I like to do some sort of a dynamic warm,
so some,
some sort of movement,
warm up dot.
Just getting on a treadmill or on a bike and,
and,
and running or biking.
I like to,
you know,
do some walking lunges,
walking lunges with a twist,
a some walking toe touches,
some quad stretches,
walking,
a skipped straight leg skips,
that type of thing to kind of get some blood flow.
Um,
and to help increase range of motion.
You know,
I have athletes start with a fun of foam roll,
um,
just to get,
again,
blood flow,
just to warm the muscles up a little bit.
Um,
uh,
or a power play,
some sort of vibration plate if you have that access to that.
And then a dynamic warm up.
And then I would,
I would then get into some,
uh,
activation.
So I do some like light glute activation where you do some hip bridges or
something like that just to fire up the glutes.
Um,
and I do some quad activation,
which would be like some no weighted step ups.
You do like two sets of eight of that by by itself.
And then you get into the export dead,
the form up,
which would be probably two to three sets that you know,
50% then 55 to 60% and in,
and then we'd work
or how many,
how many repetitions?
Five and six.
Okay.
Got It.
Five,
five to six reps of 50% of your working weight.
Correct?
Yup.
And,
and then once you get to 65%,
you'd start your,
your,
uh,
your round.
And so
how many minutes of rest between the warmup sets?
I would say a minute.
Okay.
Pretty short.
Yeah.
You're going under under a certain,
and those are full east centric.
A concentric,
eccentric or you dropped.
Okay.
Got It.
So you're not dropping the bar on these?
I am not.
No.
Got It.
All right.
Um,
and,
and so,
and then once you get into the,
into the,
into the working set,
then it would go concentrical only and I would go,
um,
and obviously you'd get right back into position.
So it's,
it stand up,
drop standup drops then have dropped eight times in a row.
Eight repetitions.
Yep.
With what percentage of your one Rep Max?
65%.
Okay.
Got It.
Yep.
For the first two weeks.
So it would be like in a hypertrophy phase and then I would,
um,
rest 30 seconds.
And then I would pair that with like a level one plyometric,
which would be like a basic squat jump.
And I would do that five times.
And more than anything.
And plyometrics,
what I think I really wanna kind of get across today is that the goal of him
doing plyometrics and training and if for an,
whether an athlete or just,
um,
looking to improve,
uh,
you know,
you're human performance.
I think the biggest thing you're trying to improve and plyometrics,
amortization phase,
which is the transition between you centric and your concentric.
And so to do that you gotta be close to or near 100%.
So I'm big on in between your plows resting to do it as hot as hard and as fast
as you possibly can to improve it.
A lot of times I think you watch a training program and you,
you see where plyometric start to become more of a like a kind of conditioning
trade.
You do it to a point where you're tired,
which is not going to help you improve what you're trying to improve,
which is amortization.
So,
um,
so I take rest in between,
so I would do like five squat jumps.
We were trying to explode as high and as fast off the ground as possible.
And you're doing that,
you're doing that in between these deadlift work sets.
Yeah.
So the superset would be a hex bar,
dead lift at eight,
uh,
with drop and then 32nd rest.
Then you do your five plyometrics.
Got It.
And you're trying to minimize ground contact in those pliers or how are you,
what makes for a good rep in the plyometrics
more than anything you're trying to,
you're trying to get to a depth that you,
that you'd feel like is natural for you to jump as high as you can.
So I'm just looking for somebody to,
you know,
in fight or flight,
they're trying to jump as high as they possibly can.
I don't really care what that looks like.
You would not,
you would not look like mine.
I think caught up,
people get too caught up in jumping.
That stretch shortening cycle that occurs in our lower body when we jump happens
in a window of 250 milliseconds.
And when we try to perfect our,
our technique and our squat jumps,
we missed that window,
right?
Which doesn't allow us to explode off the ground as fast as we possibly could.
So it's more than anything,
it's just good down and up as quick as you possibly can.
Um,
kind of as if you,
you know,
if it was firefly near the jump besides you can to save somebody or something.
So that's what I'm looking for.
And then after that with at 65%,
I would go with somewhere around a two to three minute recovery in between each
set.
Right.
Um,
once you get to 85 to 95%,
I think like as you wrote in your book,
Pryor,
uh,
is when you get to the heavy percentages,
you will,
you want to go to more of like a four to five minute recovery between a lot of
the ATP you foster and to regenerate to as close to a hundred percent as
possible.
So,
um,
wow.
Sorry,
I'm a dog is allergic might my dog hates phosphocreatine.
No worries.
Now she loves it.
She loves freaking out.
She uses a lot of foster creative.
Sorry about that.
So yeah,
as you get heavier than you'd be taking longer Resner rules and,
and for those heavier weights,
85,
95%,
are you still going to be,
say doing a work set then taking,
was it a 62nd rest?
You said before the pliers,
anywhere between 30 to 60 is dot.
Got It.
Yeah.
So born anything,
you're just looking to recover to the point where you can jump it up as close to
a full effort as possible.
Got It.
Then do five,
say,
uh,
five jumps and then rest four to five minutes or so,
somewhere in that range,
and then do the next set.
And you do that for in the case of the hypertrophy.
Now we moved,
we were talking about four sets of say eight repetitions.
When you get down into the lower rep ranges where you're doing two to five reps
at 85 to 95% of one rep Max.
How many sets are you still doing?
Three to four sets.
Are you doing a higher number of sets?
No,
I'm still doing three to four.
Okay.
Yup.
So we finished the dead lifts.
What happens after that
then?
Then I would go,
so,
so all the athletes that I,
that I,
that I bring in,
I do force plate testing with them.
So I'll do a combination of jumps,
um,
on the force plate to give me an idea of kind of there,
you know,
what their rate of force development looks like.
You know,
essentially isometric concentrically,
um,
their peak force,
a lot of different factors.
And I'll take that into consideration when I'm building their programming,
uh,
for the rest of the exercise.
But to just give you an example,
the rest of the workout will go somewhat,
um,
unilateral.
So I'll do it all single leg exercises.
So the next a group of exercises could,
could look like a Bulgarians Dumbbell,
Bulgarian split squat.
But for this particular athlete,
for you,
let's say I wanted to focus on the east centric tempo.
So what I would do with you is I would have you go lower down for five seconds
and then stand up as fast as you can for one second.
And you would do three sets of six of that.
Um,
I would then have you rest again 30 seconds to 60 seconds and that would put you
in into a position where you're seated on a bench.
I'm sitting down with one foot,
an inch off the ground,
the other foot's on the ground and do a single legs,
a concentric plyometric where you would stand up and jump as fast as you can
from a seated single leg position.
So imagine sitting in a chair both feet on the ground,
lift the left leg off the ground by one inch,
the right foot's on the ground and you jump off the right and land on the right
only.
Um,
and,
and I actually have Olympic athletes that I do this with where they'll actually
go from a seated 90 degrees seated position with one foot and they'll jump onto
a 56 inch box.
It's pretty remarkable.
Remarkable.
Yeah.
And so,
and so I think,
I don't know if I can get off the toilet with one leg,
an inch off the ground
trustee meeting too.
I,
I don't demonstrate because I'm so embarrassed in front of some of them.
I'm like,
oh no,
you demonstrated I'll bring her another athlete.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
so,
so working on,
on creating power from it,
from a static seated position.
Right.
Very similar to how you would,
if you were sprinting.
Um,
and so,
so that's a good example of the second,
um,
uh,
grouping of exercises that I would do,
for this,
for this lower body day.
Got It.
And then after the isolator role exercises,
then I would go into some sort of stability exercise,
proprioception exercise where I would go like,
um,
I call them step downs,
but imagine standing on,
on top of a bench with one foot leg hanging off of the side,
the other foot's on top of the bench and just lowering yourself slowly down for
three seconds and back to standing for three seconds.
And I would do some somewhere around one to two sets of 20 of those.
Um,
more than anything I'm focused on.
now that we burned through some larger muscle groups,
uh,
and the lower body,
I'm looking at it now that some of the stabilization muscles,
so Vmo,
glute need,
um,
and getting those fired up,
uh,
with a step down.
So it's a single except down to three seconds down,
three second step.
And you're just lowering yourself out over the side of the bench and backup.
I'm standing on the edge of the bench maji standing on the edge of a building
and lowering one foot down three inches and backup.
Got It.
And so Vmo,
that's what is it?
A vastus medialis obliques.
Yup.
And uh,
I guess one of the muscles,
when we thought responsible for a fair number of injuries,
it would,
it would seem,
or at least sort correct.
I think the biggest thing with get with the Vmo that I look at though is more
than anything imbalanced.
So I'm looking at,
uh,
a asymmetry between the [inaudible] and the rest of the quad.
If you look at,
I have a great example of this with a lot of the NFL guys I'm turning right now,
but when they come in from college is that they do so many core complex
exercises that they,
the,
the larger muscle groups kind of dominate and some of the smaller muscles
stabilizers don't,
don't get recruited as much as you'd like.
And so you'll see like a guy with a huge quad and a 12 year old girl scout size,
BMO pretty,
it's pretty unbelievable.
And that for me is a big sign that uh,
a joint stability instability.
But number two is they're at high risk and high profitability for lower
extremity injury.
And so that's something we'll,
we'll,
we'll focus on a lot.
Got It.
Where could someone,
do you have any descriptions or any video or can you point someone to any
resources if they wanted to learn how to do because I want to learn this single
leg step down in the way you're describing.
Yeah.
If I,
if I don't already have a video up on Youtube,
I will put one up there for you.
And then also to,
um,
you know,
I work with Nike on,
on their APP that they have,
which is the Nike Training Club.
Not to plug or anything,
but you got that,
that has a ton of the exercises in it.
Um,
it's actually a great kind of resource for different exercises and things that I
do that that's in there,
which you can pull from and it's free.
So,
so it's,
it's,
you know,
it doesn't cost anything.
What is your youtube account?
A prolific athletes.
Got It.
All right.
So we'll get on that by the time this comes out guys,
we'll,
we'll make sure something is up for you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And then I'll finish with seven way hips,
which I think you know all about.
You'll finish with what?
Seven way hips,
which I think,
can you describe it?
But yes,
I do know all about it.
I gave,
I gave the treacherous P to Tia credit.
It's a doctor Peter Tia mutual friend of course who,
uh,
I described wealth,
I shared a lot from Peter in tools of titans on pages 61 62 63 and these are
gluten,
mead,
uh,
at least glute mead primary exercises that you taught Peter.
So that's the seven way hip.
Yup,
that's it.
Yeah.
But I'd finished with that.
And you'd do that.
How many times a week?
We're only talking about the trap bar workouts,
but let's say you're doing this once or twice a week.
Is once a week enough for the seven way hip or would you do it more?
No,
absolutely not.
I mean,
I think gluten needs are one of the,
uh,
I one of the muscles I think for most people causing a lot of issue they don't
even know about,
especially when it comes to lower,
lower back issues.
Um,
and under developed,
uh,
glute glute meets.
So I think one of the big things I would do is I would do at least two days a
week of it,
but I have two different variations of it that,
uh,
more and more research is coming to find that you actually want to train the
glutamine,
um,
as much as you can and close chain.
So I have some exercises to,
I'll also post to that youtube account to show you better close chain,
which means feed on contact with the ground,
uh,
to,
to folks on that glutamine.
And it will do so maybe like,
you know,
seven we hips one,
one or two days a week.
And then,
and then a closed chain glutamine exercise the other day of the week I think
would be perfect.
Great.
Yeah,
I know that Amelia Boone,
who also appears in tools of titans,
so three time world's toughest mudder champion does quite a bit of the closed
chain glute made work awesome.
And I think videos would be super helpful there,
so we'll make sure that's up,
uh,
as well.
Now you did say that glute need one of those muscles that when week leads can
commonly lead to injury.
What would you say for,
not necessarily professional athletes,
but just athletes per se,
right.
Whether they're doing crossfit or Jujitsu or doesn't matter,
tennis,
fill in the blank,
right.
Someone who is a recreational athlete,
what are some of the most common culprits in terms of whether it's imbalances or
weaknesses that,
uh,
if,
if you were to put down a short list,
like the four or five that when neglected are most responsible for the injuries
that you see would blew me.
It'd be in that top four or five lists.
Oh,
absolutely.
I think it would be to be in top two.
Okay.
What's the other one in the top two ankle flection.
Ankle flection.
That is my nemesis right there.
Yeah.
So no by ankle flection you basically mean that sort of Dorsiflex and rain brain
and plan reflection.
Yeah.
And he and he version and version as well.
So I think,
I think the biggest thing is everything happens from the ground up.
So,
um,
unless you're a swimmer,
obviously there's that,
that's the one kind of caveat here is that is that,
you know,
with your feet in contact with the ground as an athlete or whether you're
crossfitting or you're running or um,
anything really at the end of the day where your feet are in contact with the
ground,
number one place your look is his,
is his feet and ankle flection.
So I think that's a big one,
especially with majority of athletes,
IC coming out,
uh,
angle fluctuates is really poor.
Um,
and something we focus a ton on because ultimately,
ultimately everything's connected.
The fascial bodies connected.
And so when there's an issue in the chain at some point,
other,
other pieces up the chain or going to overcompensate.
So whether it be you know,
more,
more attention and um,
uh,
on the knee joint or it moves up into the pelvis,
it's going to always start at the feet.
So that's where I'll,
I think number one is,
um,
and then gluten need a number two.
I would say VMO being another one.
Um,
which is really hard to target.
I think one of the big things about Vmo glute,
pretty easy to isolate the most difficult.
And one of the ways that I do that is in some of your training,
which when you're,
when you're doing it,
I think after you kind of burn through the quads,
the glutes and the hamstrings,
once your lower body begins to really fatigue is when you can then go in and
target the [inaudible] and you have to be able to target them through,
uh,
high high reps because you're going with,
you know,
you're only using your body weight,
doing some isolation exercises for the Vmo,
like,
like the step downs that I talked about,
which I'll share a video and I'll show one more other VMO exercise,
which is really,
really good.
Um,
you have to go higher rep high volume to be able to target it after you've
already fatigued larger muscle groups
because otherwise they'll overcompensate and take over the load.
So that's a big part of that.
Um,
to improve.
And is the,
is the step down,
is that also called the Peterson stepped down or is it technically different the
way that
it very well,
could I,
I'd have to look that up,
but got 'em yeah,
imagine like,
like kind of a pistol squat on the,
with one foot hanging over the side of a bench,
but you're only going down to like a 45 degree angle,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
Very cool.
All right,
we'll,
we'll make sure that is up.
So you have ankle flection,
glute mead,
Vmo,
any other,
uh,
usual suspects that you find in that list?
Uh,
you know,
this one's not so much of a,
a muscle as much as it's just internal rotation of the femur.
I think the big one of the,
the biggest,
uh,
imbalance,
the,
one of the biggest things I find with the athletes I work with,
number one is that they have minimal internal rotation of the Femur,
which is very easily,
you know,
stretch it and you can,
you can find ways to,
to,
to kind of create equal external,
internal rotation of your femur within your pelvis.
But I,
but most athletes come in to me,
you know,
really turned out really lacking internal rotation when you watch a lot of slow
motion video,
which I do a time with the athletes that train when you,
when you're watching an ACL injury happened on the field of play.
Um,
what you see is massive internal rotation of the femur and that's where the
rupture occurs.
Internal rotation,
internal rotation of the Femur.
So you see kind of the,
the,
the knee cave in go into valgus and then that's where the,
you know,
your,
your femur tries internally rotate.
If you have,
um,
range of motion there,
you can internally rotate.
You're going to actually avoid an ACL.
I have a couple of athletes that had took some big hits,
like a Russell Wilson,
the quarterback for the Seahawks this year that played through an MCL injury
that he took nine times out of 10 would have been an ACL tear.
But based on his ability to internally rotate,
um,
he was able to avoid that.
It was an MCL sprain.
He only,
he didn't even miss a practice actually with it.
Um,
I was a pretty brutal head,
but that was because of all of the work we do.
So like,
like I always tell people is that I can't eliminate injuries with the athletes I
train.
But what I can do is bring that probability as low as possible.
Um,
which a lot,
hopefully it keeps them on the field,
you know,
for long periods of time.
And for any given athlete,
you know,
I mean the worst thing that could possibly happen is,
get injured.
And so if you can lower that probability,
I mean that,
that that's the goal.
What is a good way to improve internal rotation of the femur?
And this,
this is probably also best shown by video,
but what would,
if you have,
if it's possible to describe the sort of best bang for the buck that you have
found,
what is a good way to improve internal rotation of the femur?
Sure.
There's,
there's a,
there's a fantastic stretch you can do up against a wall that I will show a
video of.
It's really difficult to explain over over audio,
but I will,
I promise you I'll post all these videos up so you guys have them,
um,
to see,
but there's one you just basically back leaning against a wall,
um,
that you can do that.
That is really helpful.
Okay,
cool.
So we'll get that in there.
And then ankle flection possible to also share any best bang for the buck there.
In terms of improving ankle flection,
this is one I really need personally.
Yes,
there is a fantastic tool out there called a pro flex.
I have no association with them and they're going to be stoked.
And I'm saying this,
but there's a basically
bro flex just like it sounds.
Yup.
It's a DCT pro flex and basically it's a board.
They created,
a physical therapist created it.
It's a board to be,
to allow you to gain leverage with your,
with your calf.
And so you put your foot into it,
looks like somewhat of a little boot,
um,
and you put your,
your,
your foot into it and then it allows you to stretch your calves and in multiple
ways,
whether it's your tab or,
or gastric,
but it,
but it really focuses and helps you kind of get stretch and strengthen through
the,
through the full range of motion planner in Dorsey flection,
unlike anything I've tried out there.
Um,
and it's kind of phenomenal product,
honestly,
and really easy to kind of,
um,
to,
to help you with the,
with the,
that fluxion.
All right.
Pro Flex.
First one's free.
That's on me.
Then you sponsor the next podcast.
All right,
so,
uh,
this is related to mutual friend of ours.
Uh,
told me a story about how you told him Robert Griffin,
the third RG three,
which I thought was c three Po or a robot because I don't follow the team.
Sports was not going to last very long.
The NFL,
and you said it very early on in his rookie season.
How did,
and it seems like that's going to be the case.
So how did you know that he wouldn't last?
Or how did you suspect that?
So,
I mean,
you know,
when you,
when you look at,
it's very similar to how a doctor w w w would look at a patient if they were
really going deep into and to kind of understanding what's going on with them.
They look into past history.
So you look into family history to look kind of into you past 10 years of,
of daily habits,
nutrition,
uh,
exercise,
all of those things.
And when you look at athletes and you,
and you get an understanding of in the past and what they've been exposed to and
what they do,
you kind of get it,
get it clear idea as to what a,
they don't need to work on or what they're going to be,
you know,
at risk of,
um,
moving,
moving forward.
And so,
uh,
one of the big things was with RG three coming out was that he was known as a
really fast athlete.
He was actually an elite level world class track and field hurdler at Baylor.
Um,
oh American actually.
And so,
um,
when he came out,
one of the things that I noticed quickly was that just based on looking at them
just from an eye test,
you could see the imbalances between no power.
You could create how fast he was.
And again,
we go back to the amount of need and the type of training he was doing when
you're a linear athlete looked like a track and field athlete running straight
ahead for long periods of time.
And that's all you do and train.
And then you transition to a sport like football where you're very,
very fast because your track and field background,
but they can transition to football where everything's happening in different
planes.
Um,
you know,
uh,
you're moving sagittal,
frontal and transverse and it's a lot of multiplanar forces that are put onto
the body that you have to train a very specific way to improve those.
And,
and a big part with what he missed out on was just training in order to absorb
those forces and in multiple planes that I knew would cause an ACL injury.
And so,
um,
and then watching his training is you kind of post a lot about his training with
like the heavy,
heavy,
deep squats that he was doing.
Um,
a lot of that,
I mean,
ultimately he was fast enough,
you didn't really need to train to continue to improve his explosiveness.
The dude already row was a worldclass hurdler.
He didn't need to improve that.
What he needed to improve was,
is ability to prevent and possibly avoid injury and,
and so instantly by just understanding what type of imbalance as track and field
athletes have and then transitioning that to what football,
what,
what stresses you're under in football.
I could tell pretty quickly that he was at extremely high risk more than any
other athlete I've assessed of,
of an injury.
And,
and unfortunately,
ultimately it kind of panned out that way.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
you can,
you can kind of get an idea of someone's kind of history and past of what,
what they do and kind of some of their imbalances as to what injuries they're at
high risk for.
I have a unrelated question than a very related question,
but before I forget,
I wanted to ask you because I was recently,
I've had exposure to hex bars for a long time starting in college,
but I,
I was recently gifted my first personal hex bar and I have,
I have it in my garage and my gym.
And there are two height settings.
I'm sure you've seen this
where
one set of grips,
if one side is up is roughly the,
I would say the same height as the,
the rest of the bar so to speak,
including where you're loading the plates and then there one that is slightly
higher.
So my question for you is when you're doing hex bar dead lifts,
how,
how many inches off the floor or how high are the grips that you would use for
your athletes?
So I generally you've had handle high hand.
Okay.
I handle.
So there's a high handle,
low annual,
you generally use how he handled.
The reason is because of the predominant,
most of the athletes I'm working with her generally over five,
10 to five 11.
Um,
and there are anywhere up to six,
seven.
So I,
I'm,
I'm usually using high handle just because I don't need two.
I don't need to put them in that type of flex.
I don't need them to be that deep.
Um,
and,
and they're not that strong at that depth.
And the,
one of the main reasons why is when you look at the athletes on a football
field,
you rarely ever see them in those positions.
So I'm not looking to just strengthen that range of motion.
We will work to improve flexibility and strength in different ways,
whether it be manually to get them in those full ranges of motion.
But when I'm training the neurally it's more,
I'm trying to increase the load as high as possible.
When you think about the central nervous system,
it adapts to stress.
So if your,
if your lower body's capable of pulling from a high handle x Bar,
dead lift 500 pounds.
But in every other exercise that you do,
you're only able to get to about three 80 or you actually stresses your nervous
system to recruit larger Modi.
And it's,
if you're only doing three 80 when you're capable of doing over 500.
And what I found is the answer was no.
And so with the,
with the high handle,
what you're able to do is increasing,
increasing,
um,
uh,
the degree of your femur and the position your pelvis and your spine and spine
angle and all of that is that you're able to go heavier,
which allows higher neural adaptation,
which you're going to treat,
look,
recruit larger motor units.
And so that's what I'm,
I'm using the hex bar dead lift,
not so much too,
you know,
increased,
hip range of motion or anything like that.
What I'm looking to do is stress the nervous system in such a way that it is,
has to recruit larger motor units in order to increase strength,
increased strength.
So that's the goal.
And so with a high handle you can generally go have you and that's why I use it.
Got It.
So even for a,
uh,
a hobbit like me,
I'm like five,
eight,
five,
nine on a good day.
If I'm like trying to put something on Tinder or something,
but
he would you suggest in that case,
I do have kind of source arms though.
So maybe that means I should also use the high handle.
Would you still use that with the uh,
shorter athletes,
people who are under five 10 or would you take them
and the lower handle?
I may take you to the lower handle,
but what,
but what I also may do is take you to lower handle then maybe add like one of
those,
you know,
10 pound plates underneath it,
just to give you an extra edge.
I don't want you too deep into it.
Like you would see like in a deep squat,
I want you to be in somewhat of an athletic,
like jumped position to where if you imagine like looking in the mirror from the
side,
if you imagine jumping and you,
you go to the depth of your jump and that's where you'd feel comfortable.
Look in the mirror,
see where that is and then align the handles to that because that's the athletic
position and that's where I want you to be.
That's where,
that's where you recruit.
You're going to recruit most or units.
And I've,
I've done more straight bar deadlift work than I have trap bar.
Where should my hands be relative to my feet?
In other words,
slightly ahead of my feet,
a slow directly in line with the side of my ankles.
Where do you suggest the,
uh,
the hands be?
Yeah,
so I mean,
the one reason interesting thing about the head,
the straight bar is that what I found when in testing it is that it had a lot
more to do with your posterior chain.
Um,
and,
and what I love about the hex bar dead lift is that because of the position,
the handles on the side of your body,
it kind of,
it's,
it's more of an anatomically correct position and it allows your body to kind of
recruit more of its,
it's skeletal muscle too to help you lift it.
And so,
uh,
basically basically you want the grip,
the middle of the handles,
you see the handles has some knurling on it.
You want to kind of grip in the middle but,
but align your hands right next to the outsides of your leg so they should be
pulling you straight up through into your hips.
So you imagine drawing a straight line from your kind of a in your inner knee
bent knee position from your,
your ankles,
shins to,
to up to your hips.
That's where you want to be.
So it's kind of think more bar path than you do.
Um,
kind of,
you know,
start position or anything like that,
like without weight,
kind of go up and down a few times and kind of see the bar path.
And that's where you're at.
Your,
your,
your alignment should be on the ground.
Got It.
Right.
So if you were to extend,
if you were to extend your hands in the proper position and do sort of a high
bar back squat type of straight down a squat,
you're,
you're kind of middle fingers would be right at the bony process on the side,
right?
Your ankles.
Got It.
That's the kind of alignment of the hands.
Cool.
And last,
last on the trap bar,
how important is it to drop the weights of versus lower than very quickly.
And,
and I'm not looking for a particular answer here.
The reason I ask is that I,
I've seen people drop in quotation marks and I've done this to bar quickly
versus drop because it takes them less time to reset and do another repetition.
Uh,
but that may just be increasing likelihood of injury with,
with doing really rapid he centrix versus just dropping the weight.
Uh,
assuming that we can do either where we're training just pretty easy these days
with the proliferation of crossfit boxes,
it love dropping shit and crossfit boxes.
Uh,
what would your,
what would your thoughts on that be?
Yeah.
You know,
so it all depends.
I think if the heavier I go with some of the athletes,
you know,
the biggest limitation is their grip strength.
And so a lot of times I'll use raps,
um,
with them to be allow them to go heavier,
especially with the female athletes I train,
uh,
when they can get up to in the 400 range or high 300 is a lot of times their
grip strength there's isn't capable of,
of,
of holding out to the bar.
And I don't want them to like increase their grip strength because I'm not
trying to add the mass.
So I add straps.
So with straps I'll generally have them like,
you know,
drop pretty quickly keeping their hands on the handle.
But for the most part it's more about efficiency and energy expenditure.
Sure.
So I'm looking at it if it's going to require a lot of energy for you to like,
so to go down with the bar and drop with it and tried to get back into position
quickly.
I'm more looking for effort on every single rep concentrically than I am kind
of,
um,
uh,
faster up.
So really ultimately comes down to you.
If you,
if you're a,
if you're good and you really quick and can get back into position fast,
uh,
by keeping your hands on the handle and just dropping with the bar,
then I'm fine with that.
I've athletes that do that all the time.
I think it's just more than anything,
it comes down to kind of comfort level with it.
And,
um,
more than anything,
not expending too much energy in the lowering of the bar.
Got It.
And do you have any preferred straps?
The users?
Just the old school.
Cool cloth straps.
Those are my favorite.
Got It.
All right.
So I promise I would,
I would reel us back to what we're talking about.
And,
uh,
we talked about ACL,
so I recently had my first ACL injury.
There may be more to it.
I did get Mris.
This was about three months ago.
I was hiking in Colorado with a number of guys,
very aggressive terrain,
45 degrees up,
45 degrees down,
lots of,
uh,
sh,
shale and so on and loaded backpacks.
And I stepped up onto a log that was about a fallen tree that was,
I'll say three feet in diameter,
something like that.
I stepped up and as I went to step off with my left leg,
my right leg went through the tree and basically caught right below the knee and
I hyper extended the knee.
It wasn't catastrophic.
I was able to continue to hike,
but uh,
had incredible pain for weeks afterwards and had trouble even walking down
stairs or walking around.
I kind of had to peg leg around and we're three months out.
Uh,
I can,
I can do controlled dead lifts even up to,
I haven't gone crazy,
but I can get over 300 without any,
uh,
exhibiting any symptoms of pain.
But I do have sub patellar soreness and this lingering concern about ACL,
uh,
I have some plans to ski coming up in a few weeks and I am concerned about it.
This is the first time I've had knee issues per se.
I've had a lot of quad issues where I've torn my legs apart,
but neat like structural knee issues.
This is relatively new for me.
So I guess there's,
there's a short term question and a long term questions.
Short term is I don't feel like I have a ton of lateral instability,
but I also don't really know what the hell I'm talking about because I've never
thought about it.
I've never worried about it before.
So how would you assess whether or not I should ski or not?
Ski would be short term and then longer term is what are some,
some good ways to minimize,
uh,
well actually to rehab an ACL injury?
Yeah.
So again,
I still don't know if they'd go therapist.
So,
so number one,
I don't want to prescribed anything to you to,
you know,
without kind of a food physical therapist in their hands on you,
I'm sure.
But I do think,
I mean,
look,
I think physical therapy is,
is an amazing field.
I think there's a lot a lot happening there that I think will become one of the
larger kind of more and more performance will be going towards physical therapy
then then it will be going the old school kind of powerlifting route.
And so I think,
you know,
if you can get into a local physical therapist,
I think that would be ideal.
I think one of the big things is I find is if it's not a rupture of the ACL,
it could be,
you know,
some sort of a,
the no grade too,
one or two sprain sprain of the MCL,
which you know,
is,
is all kind of worked through by movement and Rehab.
So I think any type of,
you know,
non weighted stability strength you can do with the VMO and the quad would be
ideal and also of the glute need.
Um,
but I would kind of,
if best you can't get under some professional guidance for that,
like at a local physical therapist,
if you have one nearby or buddy of yours,
that's one.
Um,
but,
but I think a good test would just kind of be,
um,
lightly,
you know,
testing.
It was just some like light hopping or,
or some light like jumping and landing on your,
your single leg forward and back and under it's feeling if so how much pain you
have there for the most part.
But,
but I definitely just get,
get it checked out.
I think that sounds,
I mean hyper extension is difficult because it's again,
what one of the biggest things is I'm trying to help the athletes avoid is,
is noncontact knee injuries.
But when you have something that's like,
you know,
that shearing force jarring that,
that,
that femur forward and in the joint,
which is probably what happened when you're hyper extended it.
Um,
that's,
those are,
those are tough.
Those are tough to understand.
Kind of all the,
all the different forces that went onto kind of caused that.
So I don't know,
I mean,
but if you're not in,
in a,
if you're feeling pretty decent,
you're still able to deadlift you said.
Yeah,
I'm still a little deadlift.
I deadlifted yesterday with like mid,
mid 300 without any pain,
but I was doing partial range of movement pulling basically to just above the
knee from the floor.
This is a straight bar,
uh,
and dropping because I didn't want to risk,
any type of hamstring injury.
And if I lift to the top,
I'm probably going to be lowering it quickly.
I just want to avoid the potential of east centric Lee loading my hamstrings and
some stupid way.
Uh,
so I was,
yeah,
mid three hundreds pulling to just above the knee and then dropping.
And these were relatively,
uh,
they're low rep range,
so two,
three reps and then longer rest periods.
But yeah,
no
for all intensive purposes.
Asymptomatic after that.
Like I feel fine today.
Yeah.
So I mean,
God's going to tell me if you just have a sprain,
but I would go to get checked out.
Yep.
Okay,
cool.
Uh,
question.
So we've talked about exercises that are,
hi Roy exercises that can help prevent injury.
We talked about the ankle flection of the pro flex.
We talked about glutamine and the seven way hip,
the Vmo and the uh,
step downs,
internal rotation of the femur and the weird,
it's not weird,
it's just hard to describe an audio.
We'll the wall stretch,
which we'll get video for if
there are people who would argue I'm not one of them really,
but that any exercise done properly can be done safely.
That having been said,
there are exercises that seem to produce more injuries than others.
Right.
So if,
if you were talking not about elite athletes,
but just a aspiring athletes or weekend warriors in general,
right?
You have a thousand people and you want to decrease injuries as much as
possible.
What exercises would you re or machines or anything would you remove from gyms?
100% would be the knee extension machine,
knee extension,
100% that that machine is the worst for you can possibly imagine.
Okay,
good to know.
They're there in every gym and I think it's kind of like they have to be,
but I would never do a knee extension machine ever again.
Got It.
Okay.
So knee extension out the knee extension is what any,
any runner,
runner runners up,
um,
in terms of machines or it doesn't have to do a machine.
It could be an exercise you some,
any,
any exercise that is just not worth the hazard or potential risk of injury.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I've,
I've actually worked with a lot of Olympic committees all over the world and one
of the one things I always do when I'm with them as I go and seek out the
Olympic lifting coach and kind of just pick his brain and talk him to them.
And you know,
kind of across the board,
Olympic lifting coaches would tell you to not Olympic lift unless you're an
Olympic lifter.
And the one reason they would say that is because they take elite level Olympic
lifters and take around two years to teach them the technique and a certain
lift,
whether it be the clean and jerk or to clean,
you know,
whatever overhead squat,
whatever it might be.
I think the biggest thing I would say in terms of,
uh,
that I,
and I trained a couple of crossfitters and I've actually just started doing
crossfit recently just because the crossroads I started training.
Uh,
we're given me so much crap that I've never done it,
that I was like,
fine,
I'll give it a shot and I'll,
you know,
whatever,
because I can't,
I can't talk trash about them unless I do it.
Uh,
so I'm,
I'm currently doing that,
so I actually am enjoying it.
But I would say with my background in and actually science and training for so
long,
I'm,
I'm competent in those,
in those lifts that I feel safe.
I can,
I can do them,
but I'm Wa when I'm watching people doing overhead squatting,
it just,
it kills me.
Like I sleep,
I can't do it.
And I see so many people who are just waiting for some sort of injury that,
uh,
that it just kills me.
So I would just say if you're going to get into cross where you're going to get
into any type of Olympic lifting,
really seek out somebody who's Olympic lifting certified that can help you,
you know,
you saw certified to help you,
um,
learn how to do it properly and take your time learning it before you jump into
it.
There's a lot of variations you can do.
Um,
that's what I always tell the athletes I work with too.
They're like,
well wait,
we don't power clean.
And I'm like,
no,
if I can get,
if I can do other exercises,
get the same result,
but,
but pull back all of the risk of injury.
Why,
why wouldn't I do that?
Like,
I'm not trying to get you,
I'm not training you to be a good lift.
I'm turning you to be a good football player or basketball player,
tennis player.
I'm not training you to be a great,
you know,
lift or so,
so more than anything,
it's trying to try to eliminate the risk of injury as much as possible.
So I would say if you're going to go and Olympic lifting crossfit,
really learn how to do that lift and take your time to do it before you jumped
into the classes and just go for,
you know,
five rounds of,
20 overhead squats.
Um,
and then the second would be the knee,
knee extension machines in the gym is the worst possible.
She,
you can,
you can ever do
besides the trap bar dead lift.
And I know we've already mentioned a few of the,
besides the,
the,
the hex bar dead lift.
If you had to pick one exercise two or stretch to have everyone do,
if you want it to one shot,
one kill,
treaded,
decrease injuries across the board and it,
or as many injuries as possible for say a group of a thousand people,
what would a,
what would you have them do?
Oh,
that's a good question.
I mean,
uh,
I mean seven way hips,
the one you put in until the signs.
I think it would be a really,
really good one.
Uh,
for most people did to jump in and do it.
But if we're looking at like nuts,
some exercise I came up with in my room trying to torture people,
I think something that's common,
I would say a Bulgarian split squat.
I really like.
Um,
I,
I also really like box squatting.
I think box squat is a great way to kind of teach somebody that proper
sequencing and movement,
um,
without,
you know,
putting them at risk of,
of injury.
So,
um,
I think those two would be good exercises for people to go start with.
And let's see,
massive improvement in
what height box would you have someone start with a generally just you
want to look in the side of the mirror,
sit down on a box and you're looking for a 90 degree angle.
I got it.
All right,
so you're looking for nine degree angle,
meaning quads parallel to the ground.
Okay,
got it.
Yeah.
All right.
Now the,
so this,
this is something I'd love to dig into and this relates to a story of how you
helped meb and you're going to have to pronounce this guy's last name for me.
I could fluffy Husky.
All right.
Train for his incredible Boston marathon victory.
So can you explain for us,
maybe tell the story of what inspired you to apply your sprinting insights to
marathoner and how you trained him?
Yeah,
I mean just really,
really simply stride length and frequency is product of mass specific forest.
If you can help somebody increase their mass specific force,
naturally those two things are going to occur when you're a marathon runner on
average will take around 20,000 strides to run a marathon.
Well,
if I can increase your stride length because of increasing your math specific
force and your normal running gait by two by three inches,
let's say,
right?
So big increase,
three inches on every,
in your normal running great in your stride length,
three inches times 20,000 and 6,000 inches,
which is around 5,000 feet,
which is close to a mile.
So you're a mile ahead of where you were last time you ran that marathon,
just purely by increasing your mass specific force.
It's that simple.
Got It.
And what,
how did your training differ if at all,
for Med versus your sprinter?
Mean,
sprinters,
meaning track and field or football players fill in the blank.
Yeah.
So,
so,
um,
majority of marathoners don't have,
don't have a kind of desire to get in the weight room and strength train.
I think a lot of eh,
you know,
kind of for a long time thought has been that it can only go to,
to hurt you and injure you or add size,
which is what most marathoners don't want.
And so the biggest thing was just teaching him that bye.
Hex Bar,
dead lift,
you know,
training and just the concentric zone only.
So not doing no he eccentric loading that he can eat again.
Stresses,
nervous system,
recruit motor units without larger mornings,
without adding any,
any weight.
So you started at 127 pounds,
ended on 127 pounds and,
and um,
by just that one exercise I didn't touch is running.
I didn't touch anything else that he did in the weight room.
It was just simply that one exercise once a week.
Um,
it improved his,
his,
his started like this running game in turn helped him run faster.
Love it.
I love the simplicity of it.
I mean,
super efficient.
Simple doesn't mean easy,
but,
no,
I think,
I mean,
I,
I think,
you know,
one of the things I've,
I've always kind of really loved about what you,
what you're doing and it's the same kind of approach I take and you look a lot
of people that they're successful in what they do.
I think they take that team approach as you look at patterns or you just look at
when you're trying to do is you're just trying to look at the most important
things you can actually have control over to improve,
um,
that,
that has the greatest effect the most amount of ways.
But with the simplest approach is just keep it as simple as possible.
And I think that really not only helps the,
I mean elite level athletes but helps everyday people.
I think that's the biggest misconception.
I always have people ask me,
you know,
well what's,
well they're elite athletes and um,
you know,
when I started working with Nike,
well yeah,
but you know,
take apart what you do with elite level athletes and apply that to,
to everyday people.
And um,
and what I always try to say is that there's nothing different.
I mean,
with the exception of they may be genetically predisposed to have greater talent
and catching a ball or throwing a ball fast or running faster or whatever it
might be.
Ultimately their time in their day is the same as yours there.
Their ability to,
and the how hard certain workouts are the same as yours.
Um,
it's just that,
you know,
they're,
they're true.
Maybe training for just a little bit of a different purpose so they're still
looking for the most bang for their buck and trying to,
you know,
keep it as simple as possible even though there are elite just like the everyday
are
definitely.
What do you,
uh,
you mentioned Nike.
What are you working on at Nike that you can talk about?
I know there's some stuff that's probably off the table,
but what else?
Absolutely general,
what have you been recruited to do?
I think the biggest thing is just is that the,
the performance training and fitness fueled is,
it's,
it's growing really quickly.
I think,
um,
people are,
are,
are really starting to understand how important fitness is for their overall
health.
And,
and so I think what,
um,
my role at Nike as a senior director of performances is to,
is to really help kind of bring,
bring in and using like the Nike trainer network or the performance council of
some of the top minds in the field to help kind of funnel information and in
training,
um,
modalities and ideas and workouts into an app,
uh,
experience for everyone to be able to,
to use and,
and kind of,
um,
as a way.
So it's a free app called Nike Training Club,
which I'm working on it basically a personal trainer,
your pocket.
So,
uh,
our goal is there's different technology or will be coming out with soon that
we'll be able to give you really in depth assessment of um,
you,
you know,
where you're starting from,
your imbalances,
weaknesses,
those types of things,
and then kind of prescribe a training program using algorithms that will be
unique to you and helping you improve whatever you're trying to prove.
Whether it's weight loss or strength gain or getting ripped or running a faster,
you know,
half marathon or,
or if you're a game day athletes at the high school level trying to make your
football team,
um,
it's going to be a,
you know,
geared and you unique for you based on your assessment.
So,
um,
just kind of bringing together the best minds in the field that I,
that I can bring together and then Nike can bring together to kind of deliver
that through a digital experiences is,
is the goal.
Cool.
Can't wait to check it out.
Yeah.
We were talking,
you mentioned earlier your eye's bleeding when you watch people doing horrific
overhead squat attempts,
especially if they're trying to do as many reps as possible.
In a minute or after they're already about to pick their brains out or something
like that.
Uh,
which by the way,
people wandering a lot harder to do a proper overhead squat than you would think
you need.
Uh,
well most people would need very good ankle flection,
really good thoracic mobility so that they,
they're not completely destroying their shoulders.
Uh,
besides that,
what other things,
and it could be anything.
It doesn't have to be exercises.
What other stuff drives you crazy when you see it at a gym?
Good question.
Besides,
besides guys and like affliction,
tee shirts,
doing preacher curls while they stare into their eyes in the mirror besides
that.
Oh Man,
I have a funny story on that.
And uh,
you know,
I think,
I think the biggest,
what I hate,
I hate people running on treadmills.
That's number one.
Uh,
why do you hate people running on treadmills?
just,
I,
I just think it promotes,
uh,
bad running mechanics.
I think it's,
it's just people kind of tend to like roll that way when they,
there's a street right outside,
they can just go run on.
And there's a lot of technology out there that helps them track and I get an
idea of exactly what they're doing.
I've tried to just on the road,
but,
um,
I think,
you know,
I don't know.
That's tough.
I think I've already told you about leg extension machine.
That one kills me.
Um,
what else?
Ah,
okay.
Well the good,
I can't go to a high school or younger bath game to watch people run it.
It drives me absolutely crazy.
Like I can't watch people run,
um,
that haven't been taught how to run properly and they're just,
you know,
doing bud kicks behind them all backside mechanic that like,
just watching people,
not how to run no outer run properly is my pet peeve.
I think that that one,
I have a hard really hard time or like you when to watch somebody going on a run
on the side of the road and like I really just want to pull over,
stop and get out the car and just work on their mechanics with them just for
like five minutes and then will save them so much pain and an injury that,
um,
and most of it's just by overstriding I think biggest,
could you explain what you mean by that?
Oh,
so when you thinking about,
I talked about earlier,
when you think about foot strike,
when the,
when the foot strikes way out front in front of your pelvis and when your foot
law one pond ground ground contact is out in front of your pelvis from when
you're looking at somebody from the side.
Um,
that's,
that's overstriding and I think that's the number one cause of injury and static
running when you,
if you talked to a lot of physical therapists,
um,
and so just that alone,
if you could help fix overstriding,
that would help eliminate a ton of injury in static runner.
So that's right.
Kind of a mission of mine.
What are some of the tips that you would give in those five minutes to fix
overstriding?
Is it more forward lean?
Is it,
I have no idea.
I'm not a runner,
but what would your,
I know a lot of people who are certainly,
what would some of the recommendations be that you would give that person in
your five minutes once you've convinced them you weren't going to Mug them or
that you weren't completely insane?
Well,
that's the hard part I think is that it's difficult to do it.
I mean,
a lot of times I was just telling him my NFL combine is the other day they were,
they were asking me like,
what?
You know what you're teaching me?
It feels so uncomfortable and awkward and I was like,
exactly your slow.
So therefore being fast should feel uncomfortable and awkward.
We're placing facet full,
uncomfortable,
awkward.
We'd have our problem because you're not,
you're good.
I think that's the hard part is that it should,
it should feel a little bit awkward and uncomfortable when you first start doing
it.
Right.
So it's difficult to do it on your own without somebody watching you from the
side.
But generally it's just the feeling of your foot landing almost,
almost behind you,
like directly you or behind you.
And
you'll know most likely it's,
it's landing someone underneath you.
So kind of get that feeling of,
of foot placement underneath you or behind you.
And I think that'll,
that'll help a lot.
Just don't reach out in front of you to run.
Got It.
What,
what do well here,
I'll give you two questions.
You can answer either one.
So one is what is something you believe in?
It doesn't have to be limited to what we've been talking about,
but what is something you believe that other people think is insane?
Or what do,
if you had to pick one thing,
you believe that a lot of trainers disagree with you on,
what would that thing be?
It could be either.
No,
I think.
MMM.
Oh,
there's all,
there's probably a lot.
I mean,
I think it's probably a lot less
get into it.
Whatever you want it to,
whatever you can mention.
Yeah.
You know,
I think the number one thing is,
is that,
but my biggest frustration in the field of,
of,
of training human performance is that I think everyone's constantly trying to be
the expert and making things so complicated that you have to see,
see,
a trained professional to understand.
I think my biggest thing is that it's not that difficult.
It's very simple.
And I think the more this is more,
the simpler we can make it,
the better it is for everybody,
including the one those teaching it.
Um,
I think we try to get so complicated,
uh,
and,
you know,
kind of put our own spin and making it,
we're the expert in certain things that,
that it just becomes kind of,
I'm on digestible for,
for,
for most people.
So I think my biggest thing is just make it as simple as you possibly can.
Whether you're working with the Levi level athletes or you're working with,
you know,
um,
sedentary adults.
I,
it doesn't matter,
it just,
just make it as simple as possible because ultimately you can only improve so
many things at once.
Just focus on,
on whatever,
you'll get the most bang for your buck out of it.
And I think start there and you can start to add things on.
Um,
and,
and I think that's the biggest thing.
I think,
uh,
you know,
for me,
I think it's just keeping it as simple as possible.
And I think we tried to make it a lot more difficult.
I think people always say,
well,
you know,
how,
how do you,
how can you just predict,
you know,
someone's speed based on just an expert at looking body weight will,
there's an algorithm that goes into it and there's been eight years of data
collected on,
you know,
thousands of athletes that,
that helped me drive to that it's not just,
Oh,
just do this and that,
and it's,
you know,
there's a lot that goes to it,
but,
but by me just keeping it really simple by just saying,
just increase your strength without increasing your lean muscle mass,
you,
you'll improve your speed.
It,
it's,
I think it's more helping more people than it,
than it is to kind of,
um,
I can't sell that.
So it's not that I'm trying to sell anything,
it's more than anything.
It's just trying to keep it as simple as possible.
So people's kind of remove the riff Raff from,
uh,
you know,
their daily thing.
I don't know if you saw the story,
there's a story today,
uh,
in,
um,
on ESPN about the University of Oregon and there's three players from the
university,
Oregon's football team that were hospitalized due to Rhabdo,
which
she's so revved my license.
You want to describe what,
what Rhabdo is for people who don't know?
Yeah,
sure.
It's basically caused by super intense workouts,
overtraining to the point where your muscle tissue breaks down and gets into the
bloodstream and releases toxins and can actually lead to kidney failure.
It's something that we haven't seen and I'm not kidding.
I think like 80 years,
uh,
crossfit,
yes.
When they do gyms that that occurs here and there.
Yeah.
So there was,
but as there were hospitalized and,
and,
and basically the coach that was training them was trying to break them down
basically.
And,
um,
you know,
doing certain exercises that just really at the end of the day he was just
trying to break them mentally and that was really for no reason.
Other than that there's no sports performance aspect behind it.
Um,
but a lot of,
a lot of coaches out there,
when I talked a lot of high school,
you know,
strength coaches are a lot of college drinkers.
When I go around speaking in different places,
it's just that I think we get so caught up in kind of what we used to do.
We miss out on ultimately what's best for the people we're working with and how
can we be on the front edges of that,
of improving it.
I just,
I'm not comfortable sitting here today saying I accept where we are as far as
we've come in training that I'm willing to sit on my laurels,
just use what we have currently.
Like I want to push the limits.
I think we're on the W we've barely even scratched the surface on human,
on human potential.
And I think a lot of that has to do with just regurgitated information and,
and,
and not people looking and seeking out better ways to do something.
And I think that's my biggest thing is it's not so much that I never speak in
absolutes.
I don't think we're ever,
we've ever reached the finish line,
especially in this field.
I think it's always,
you've got to always kind of focused on this is what I'm currently doing today.
I hope in two years I have a better way to train athletes than just the x bar
down.
If I really truly do,
I hope the force number is obsolete in two years because I hope we've moved on
to something that is better and more and safer and more people can do it to help
them improve their performance.
And then at the end of the day,
my goal would be is if you can,
if you can even the playing field of genetics and talent and you can actually
teach people how to be faster than it's going to come down to who works the
hardest is going to win.
And I think that's what my goal is ultimately is not to,
it's to remove the veil of kind of mystery of what makes somebody elite and
show,
okay,
here's,
here's what you need to do.
If you could do these three things,
do this over a long period of time.
And it's just who's going to put in the most work is going to reach that goal.
And I think more and more,
you know,
in other fields we're seeing that.
Um,
but I think my goal with training is just to kind of continue to push the
envelope and not accept kind of what is and kind of keep pushing forward.
Which,
which trainers or books have most influenced or impressed you?
And the reason I ask,
I have,
uh,
Charlie Francis,
his book on speed.
Charlie,
he was amazing.
And some of you may recognize that name because he was the trader of Ben
Johnson.
Now at that level,
you don't have to comment,
but
I will say with a fair degree of certainty,
not the only guy doping in that race.
I mean,
I think we've already got back.
I haven't ever gone back and seen that like eight of the seven of the eight
people in that race were doping.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's
Charlie,
Charlie that people miss out on the genius purely based on kind of the story
with Ben and,
and people thinking he's,
he's bad guy because he did well when it was just the name of the game.
I mean,
I tell people all the time,
you're sitting in a major league baseball locker room in late eighties early
nineties and you're looking around and you hit 20 home runs a year before and
the guy next to you hit 12 and the following year he gets 40 and you're still
hitting 20 at some point you're going to go,
you know what?
I got to get on what everybody else is getting on.
Otherwise I'm not going to be able to play very much longer.
And I think,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of almost,
they're the product of the culture.
It's not so much an isolated incident as much as people think it is.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
outside of that,
no,
Charlie Francis,
absolutely.
It was a huge,
massive influence on me.
Um,
another,
a three time Olympian,
a hurdler,
a guy by the name of Tony Campbell who became a two who's still a track and
field coach show was a huge influence on me.
Damn Path is,
is,
is one of the,
I think,
brilliant minds of,
of not just track and field the training period.
He runs all of this down to Phoenix,
which is one of the largest kind of attended a track and field centers in the
world.
Altice a l t u S.
Yeah,
alt u s um,
and Dan path.
It's p f a f F.
Brilliant guy in mind.
Um,
but you know,
I study everybody.
Tim,
honestly,
I,
I mean I've,
I've got from,
you know,
Louie Simmons to child porn and to all of them.
I mean for me it's,
it's kind of like says success leaves clues and I think you've got to kind of
study the best that that had done it prior to you and see what,
see where we're at and then see what we can kind of add onto.
You know,
Buddy Morris,
he was a strength coach with the Arizona cardinals.
A really good friend of mine,
you know,
phenomenal coach.
He,
he's,
you know,
been in the game for a very long time,
is in his sixties was kind of a Louis Westside barbell guy.
But,
uh,
it has kind of adjusted to really evolve and he's doing some phenomenal things
with them.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean there's a ton of coaches that I,
I,
you know,
respect incredibly,
I think,
I think it's been awesome.
I think more than anything we,
we as a field of performance coaches have to kind of,
and what my goal is with Nike is trying to bring us together to kind of get,
you know,
bringing all that information together and try to kind of come with some
breaths,
best practices and try to help move this field forward.
What,
is there anything in particular from uh,
Louis Simmons for you?
People who don't know who Louie Simmons says you got to look,
this guy is awesome and I'm not going to say too much more.
He's very well spoken,
very smart,
a checkout,
his tattoos,
a reward.
He has to say about anabolic.
It's,
and then look at the athletes who have come out of his gym in the last 20 years
and just prepare to have your mind blown.
Do Yeah.
If you've,
if you've ever seen people using chains or bands,
uh,
chances are they,
they borrowed it from Louie Simmons or if they,
uh,
but is there anything in particular that you have,
borrowed or adapted from Louie that comes to mind?
Yeah,
absolutely.
When I went to meet with them,
you know,
one of the big things he was talking to me about is that with all in this was
just recently,
but he will all of his world record and,
and and you know,
worldclass squatters that he has,
he,
he box squats all of them to improve their squat.
So as basic of a lift this box,
what is,
he uses that to help them improve their deep squat,
uh,
in their power lifting a competition.
So that was one thing I started implementing more and more with a lot of my
jumpers.
A lot of my football players is using more box squat and then um,
then than deep squatter or any type of variation of squad.
I,
I use the box squat a ton and I as a teaching tool,
but just to help them improve their other exercises of minimizing the risk of
injury and training.
Question on box squat.
Just a technical nuance said,
are you with your athletes when they box squat,
how much of your weight,
how much of their weight,
do you have them transfer from their feet to their ass on the box?
Uh,
if at all?
Or is it just making contact and then reversing the movement?
It just depends on the weight I'm using.
Um,
and also kind of what I'm going for if I'm using,
if I'm using it like to,
to do tempo.
So if I'm doing like four seconds down controlled tempo,
I may have them,
um,
just touch and go.
I may have them.
It just depends on what I'm,
where I'm at in the phase of training or what I'm trying to do to teach.
Sometimes I'll a lot of times a week newer athletes to box squatting,
I'll actually have them sit completely down on the bench or on the,
on the,
I'm sorry,
on the box.
Um,
kind of sit up rights to their spine angle is,
is perpendicular to the ground and,
and then lean back forward and stand back up.
Just to kind of get the understanding of the sequencing of the movement that I
want.
Um,
that from what I was saying,
that's what Louis does as well as he actually has them sit completely down in
the box.
Um,
and so,
um,
I kind of do a combination of the two which just kind of bends on the,
for the,
the,
the um,
kind of phase of the training I'm in.
But for the most part of the listeners,
I would say I'd probably sit all the way down in the box and then tilt your
spine angle back forward and stand back up
when you're,
when you're working with elite football players or sprinter.
Certainly I would imagine they're already,
they already tend to be very low body fat there.
There are probably exceptions depending on the,
yeah,
there are probably exceptions depending on the position,
but with,
for talking about the
not ground reactive force exactly,
but the,
the amount of weight they can lift relative to their body weight.
Are there cases where you focus simultaneously or not on dropping as much body
fat as possible since that would extensively contribute to their ability to run
faster?
Right.
I mean you're just tweaking a different variable.
Oh,
a hundred percent yeah.
I have a good example of that.
Actually a couple of years ago I had two quarterbacks going coming into the NFL
draft,
Marcus Mariota and Jamis Winston and one came in at 207 pounds and needed to be
two 25 the other one came in at two 60 I needed to be two 30 so I actually had
one needing to gain 20 and the other one needing to lose 30 and and had them at
the exact same time.
And so,
um,
yeah,
this,
this ultimately can work for either.
What did you do in both of those cases?
I know you could probably talk for hours about it,
but if you had to do your best to summarize what worked best for those two guys.
One trying to cut fair amount of body fat and then the other trying to gain
mass.
What,
what were the keys in those two cases?
No,
I mean,
yeah,
ultimately it comes down to,
I mean,
as you know,
nutrition plays a massive role in it.
And so blood testing,
I mean I,
I do a lot of blood tests work with,
with the guys and so as you know,
with high levels of insulin,
glucose is really difficult to lose body fat.
So understanding their diet and that perspective of trying to lower that,
those markers as much as possible,
eliminate sugar and those types of things that have them lose body fat is,
is crucial.
Um,
but at the end of the day,
that's,
that's the really cool part about a lot of this training is that a lot of it is
going to get you to some sort of level of homeostasis.
Your body is going to try to get to its natural state,
uh,
somewhat of a zero based on all of this training.
So whether you need to lose weight or you need to put on muscle,
your body's going to adapt and do what it needs to do in order to increase its
strengths,
especially when it's being stressed at certain levels with the hex bar dead
lifts.
So with a guy like Marcus who needed it to gain 20 pounds,
I added a lot more youth centric loading into his training programming.
So He'd do a lot more tempo,
time,
attention and focus on the eccentric phase of some of the exercises as well as
well as uh,
the concentric.
So an export data,
for example,
I'd have him go up and down,
um,
because we were looking for more like cross sectional muscle fiber.
And then,
and then with Jamis it was,
it was a lot of concentric,
only eliminate limited east centric focus from his,
his training,
um,
and then just upping the intensity and also his cardio.
So just giving him some,
some more,
uh,
cardio throughout the day.
And for him,
a big part was just diet.
I mean,
a lot of these kids coming out of college,
a lot of a lot of people don't realize is that they have no idea how to eat
right or what is,
what is eating right.
They've gotten away so much on talent up to that point that all of a sudden it
comes to the point where,
oh wait,
I got to really focus on what I have to eat now.
You know?
So it's like,
yeah,
no,
mcdonalds and KFC is not not good for you.
Uh,
which people,
you'd be amazed at how much they don't understand that,
but I,
you know,
just helping him with his dad was a big part.
So ultimately the training doesn't need to change as much as it's like,
when you look at crossfit for exams is a great example.
You'll see some people in the gym over 60 days that will put on tons of muscle
mass and,
and you know,
and get stronger and bigger and you'll look at the other side of the room and
said,
we'll lose 105 pounds.
And it's like,
whoa.
How did them in the same workout,
same programming over this past six C's get totally different opposite results
and ultimately just because the body's trying to find that,
that,
that zero,
that homeostasis.
So it's whether it's burning fat cells or,
or,
or increasingly muscle mass,
it's going to do whatever you know is,
is asking you to do.
Right.
What's a,
just a,
just a couple more questions and I'll let you back to your night.
But the
first question that I always ask is what books have you gifted the most to other
people?
And these don't have to be sports related,
but they could be,
uh,
are there,
are there any particular books that you've gifted
to mammal?
Good question.
I've heard you asked this before.
I didn't dig.
You're asking me and it should have been prepared for this,
but I,
I'm a huge,
huge avid reader.
Um,
I mean I truly believe,
I tell every person I trained is that I think the big one of the biggest reasons
you are where are there,
if it's been where you are,
where you are and where you want to go is kind of knowledge I big and reading as
much as you can.
And so that's a tough question.
I think the alchemist is a big one.
I've,
I've loved that book for a very,
very long time.
Um,
the Bible is a big one,
but I'll give you a kind of an off,
off,
off the wall kind of one,
which is called the slight edge.
If you ever heard of that book,
the slight edge.
The slight edge.
Oh,
slight edge.
Yeah.
So basically the premise of the book is,
is,
and I give it to as many athletes as I possibly can.
Um,
the,
it's basic,
the premises,
what you,
the small,
little tiny things you do,
the daily habits you do every single day can lead to exponential kind of life
improvement down the road.
So it's basically talks about,
okay,
for me habits before they form you.
And,
and what types of habits you want to form.
So whether it's things like you talked about all the time,
which is journaling,
uh,
nutrition,
um,
you know,
relationally,
like all those things that you,
that,
that will help you lead a greater,
fuller,
happier life.
Kind of making sure that you do those,
those things and Redo them religiously every single day.
And over the course of time,
like compounding interest,
it will add up to something great at,
you know,
down the road.
And,
um,
it's all about just kind of forming those habits.
I,
and I,
that's something I work with my athletes on all the time because ultimately
they've all gotten to where they are.
But what,
what separates the great ones,
the all time athletes and people from,
from kind of the,
you know,
the good is I think those kind of dis,
discipline daily habits that they do every single day.
That,
that kind of,
you know,
make them who they are.
They are.
And that's what separates them from everybody else.
They know who they are.
Um,
they know that they can only do a few things really,
really well and they focus on those things and without fail they do them every
single day.
You know this,
I'm so embarrassed,
I can't remember the name but a,
I love the title be.
It reminds me of this anecdote or a story I heard about one of the most famous
basketball coaches of the last century certainly,
and I'm blanking on the John Wooden.
Yes,
John Wooden.
And this may or may not be true.
I think it is that he would sit his players down at the beginning of a season,
have them take off their shoes and then have them lace their shoes back on
according to his instructions and the point of the exercise because people are
like,
why the hell are we doing this?
This is ridiculous.
Why do I need to change how at least my shoes?
And he said improperly a fitted shoes cause blisters,
blisters,
cost points and points,
cost games.
And the moral of the story being that it's the little things done consistently
that make a huge difference now that you have to pay attention to.
The details.
So I love that.
Yeah.
Hundred percent.
Yeah,
the slight edge in it.
It's a redundant book.
It just goes and you know,
cover it covers the same things over and over again.
Um,
but it's just,
it's,
it's kind of,
you know,
there's all these self help books out there that kind of give you like
breakthroughs and certain things.
This,
this one is awesome because that kind of gives you the,
before all of that happens you've got to be able to do these things really well.
Um,
and it talks about like four or five things that you do daily that that just
will add up at some point there.
They're good habits that will,
that will pay off,
you know,
exponentially.
And in the end,
I love it.
What advice would you give your 30 year old self and if you could just place us,
where are you?
How old are you right now?
I'm 34 okay.
Forget about that question.
Well yeah,
let's say you're 20 or 25 year old self,
whichever one needs the advice the most.
And if you could just cut,
try to place us where you are and what you're doing.
20 or 25
man,
I think.
I think the biggest thing would be to,
I'll tell you a funny story.
My so well,
I first started doing this,
my,
my dad would always tell people that,
that I was,
well,
I mean I still,
when I first started this,
I started to figure out what I want to do and training.
I even started out where I was like at a 24 hour fitness because I just wanted
to get an idea of like what I wanted to do.
And to this day my dad still tells everybody I'm a personal trainer.
But I think it's pretty funny.
Um,
well for multiple reasons,
but I think it's,
it's,
but I think more than anything it's,
it's that whatever,
whatever you're going to do be,
be the absolute best at it.
And I think ultimately it always works out in the end.
And,
and I would have never thought in a million years when I was younger that like,
you know,
I thought I was kind of not being an athlete and not being kind of,
I didn't know how I want to be an orthopedic surgeon,
but not,
but not having none of those things really work out for me.
I would've never guessed that would reach level access to success that I have
today based on what I was doing.
But I took so much pride and,
and,
um,
put so much effort into like helping every single person that it came across to
improve that.
Ultimately,
it kind of started to add up and I think I just wanted to be the best,
absolute best that I could be.
Um,
are you from or the author Cs Lewis?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yes.
About Screwtape letters.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Some great.
But once a big things,
he talks about it.
It's what's called the inner circle.
I think w w w when I was talking to the athletes I work with,
I'm always talking about,
you know,
they're always striving to be within that inner circle.
Whether they see people like Jay z or Beyonce or you know,
big time athletes that they like,
you know,
Tom Brady or whoever they want to be in that circle with those athletes because
they see them,
they're all hanging out,
running around.
But ultimately those people in the,
in that inner circle,
they don't even know they're in that inner circle.
The reason they're in that inner circle is because other people that were
amazingly great at what they did recognize their greatness and what they did.
And that's why it's the inner circles a lot of times made up of photographers or
actors or musicians or athletes or all these different types of people,
because ultimately they're the best of what they do.
And other greatness recognizes greatness.
So instead of focusing on getting into the inner circle,
focused on being great at whatever you're doing,
and I promise you at the end of they are going to look up and you'll be in the
inner circle.
And I think that's,
that's for me telling my younger self that is that just,
just be great at what you're doing and ultimately you'll be recognized for that.
Not,
not trying to,
you know,
get into the inner circle in any other way,
I guess,
if that makes sense.
Makes perfect sense.
Well,
Ryan,
this has been awesome.
This is,
I'm really glad we connected and had a chance to chat.
I'm sure we will have a million followup questions from,
and,
uh,
plenty of room for round two.
So whether it's in Oregon or in San Diego or somewhere else,
would be fun to,
to grab a bite to eat and do some dead lifts.
Uh,
but where can people find you if there's preferred place on social media?
You'd like people to say hello or anything else you'd like to mention where,
where can people find you and more about your work?
Yeah,
sure.
So,
I mean,
yeah,
I'm I working at Nike now so it's a little bit different,
but I mean I'm on Instagram,
a Ryan flirty,
won outright and flirty and the number one,
um,
and then uh,
by email justRyan@prolificathletes.com is my personally most over you and
sending you know,
questions there if you guys would want.
Um,
and I'd be happy to get back to you as soon as I can.
I think those are probably the two probably best places to find a prolific
athletes.com is still up.
But,
but uh,
because I'm at Nike now that no longer really kind of operating that website
anymore.
So I would just focused on sending an email or,
or the ends or Instagram.
Got It.
All right.
Well you may be getting a lot of emails,
sir.
So hopefully you have in the autoresponder that helps you to ignore anything you
really don't want to answer.
But once again,
thanks for taking the time.
This has given me a bunch of homework and things to look into and uh,
two people listening.
As always,
we will have show notes,
links to resources including the exercises that we discussed,
whether it's a glued mead,
Vmo,
step downs,
internal rotation of the Femur,
etc. We will have these available and we will figure out the best links for
those and put them in the show notes and you can find those show
notes@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast or if that's too hard to spell,
you can just go to tim.blog/podcast and I'll have the show notes for this
episode and every other episode.
Uh,
Ryan,
thanks again man.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my pleasure,
Tim.
Thanks so much
and a to everybody listening,
as always,
thank you for tuning in and more episodes come and say,
hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com.
That's four hour workweek.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one if you sign up.
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
I have used legal zoom myself for many of my businesses,
and many of the icons on this podcast have actually used legal zoom.
For instance,
Matt Mullenweg of wordpress fame CE of automatic,
which is now worth more than a billion dollars first incorporated his company on
legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses.
Whether that's setting up a will,
doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit or finding simple cease and desist letter templates.
Man,
do I use a lot of those?
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they do have a network of independent attorneys available in most states.
They can give you advice in the best way to get started,
provide contract reviews and otherwise help you run your business and important,
there are no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency.
That means upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a satisfaction guaranteed.
Checkout Legal zoom.com today to see how they can make life better and easier
for you and your business.
If you're pretending to be a lawyer on the Internet,
then you are asking for trouble.
Put together the safety nets,
get your t's crossed and your I's dotted.
Enter Promo Code Tim.
Tim.
At legal zoom.com to save 15% that's t I m for 15% off.
Check it out.
Legal zoom.com this episode is brought to you by [inaudible] dot com the world's
largest on demand massage service.
What?
And let me tell you,
I have a high bar for this stuff.
I have body work done at least once week cause I broke my body.
I have 30 plus fractures and hunted plus Mris.
I need bodywork.
So I have a very,
very,
very high bar for that sooth which I've tested.
I tested my assistant's tested,
my employees tested,
delivers a hint,
selected,
licensed and experienced massage therapist to you in the comfort of your own
home,
hotel or office in as little as an hour.
I've tested them in San Francisco,
I've tested them at Austin,
I've tested them all over the place and I have to say I was really,
really amazed at the quality of therapist and I do not accept mediocrity at all
in this area.
The process is super simple.
Think of it as Uber for massages,
right?
You choose the kind of massage you want,
say Swedish or sports massage,
deep tissue,
whatever.
Then a,
if you want,
you can opt for a couple's massage and I imagine that's an edge case as the tech
people say,
but whatever you sit,
the lengthier massage,
so let's see what 60 minutes,
90 minutes,
two hours,
and let's be real.
If you want a proper massage,
go for 90 or 120 minutes for God's sake and you select the gender of your
therapist and then click you're off to the races and they bring the massage
table sheets,
oil music so you can unwind no matter where you are.
And I have used this at Airbnbs,
hotels,
et Cetera,
et Susan's in 50 cities including most major us cities as well as the London,
Sydney,
Melbourne,
Toronto and Vancouver.
So number one,
download the APP,
sooth,
s,
O,
t,
h,
e in the ios app store,
Google play store,
and then use the code.
Let me try that again and use the code.
Titan 20 t I t a n two zero titan 20 all caps to get $20 off of your first
massage.
That's a lot.
That's a very good discount.
So you should use it.
So again,
download the APP,
sooth s,
O,
t,
h,
e,
and try out the code titan 20 all caps for $20 not percent,
$20 off your first massage.
And if you're anything like me,
I have been paying and I've been enjoying.
So give it a shot.
Try out sooth and your muscles,
nervous system and sleep.
Well,
thank you for it.
What the fuck gotta read was that it was pretty good.
That's what I think.
Okay.
Enjoy.
Bye.